おはようございます。
6月8日、アイプリニュースをお届けします。
今日もおねがいアイプリ、ひみつのアイプリ、そしてアイプリバースの最新情報をわかりやすくお伝えします。
まずは、アイプリバースからの新情報です。
6月11日木曜日から、おねがいアイプリ2だんがスタートします。
今回の注目は、新キャラクターおりびあの登場です。
おりびあちゃんは、アニメ10話でも素敵なライブを披露しました。
そのライブで着ていたコーデはゆうきのフラワーバズリウムで、6月11日からゲーム機で楽しめます。
おりびあちゃんのカードはデュオコーデもあり、あおいちゃんやぐみちゃんとのペアで遊べるのが魅力です。
アイプリバースで新しいステージが広がりますので、ぜひチェックしてください。
続いて、現在好評稼働中のアイプリバースおねがい1だん後半のフルコーデガチャ情報です。
6月10日水曜日までの期間限定で、マジカルミラクルパープルやほしのゆうびんやさんゆめかわ、ポップンマシュマログリーンなど、かわいいフルコーデが手に入ります。
1回300円で、★4コーデがゲットできるお得なガチャです。
いのりちゃんとあおいちゃんのかわいいコーデも登場中で、すきすきハートバズリウムやゆめゆめスターバズリウム、トキメキトゥインクルピンク、トキメキトゥインクルブルーなど、見逃せません。
おねがいアイプリのゲーム機があるお店では、サンリオキャラクターズとのコラボレーションキャンペーンも開催中です。
6月6日土曜日からスタートしており、サンリオキャラクターズのかわいいアイプリカードがもらえます。
コラボ楽曲なかよしパーティーも大人気で、いのりちゃんとあおいちゃん、そしてハローキティちゃんが一緒に歌う特別バージョンも楽しめます。
ゲームをプレイしながら、ぜひコラボの世界を満喫してください。
アニメおねがいアイプリも注目の10話が放送されました。
おりびあちゃんがれおんくんを勇気づける感動のライブシーンが話題です。
見逃した方やもう一度見たい方は、レミノやアニメタイムズのプライムビデオチャンネルで最新話が配信されています。
これからのエピソードも期待大です。
さらに、みんなで踊ろう！
アイプリおねがいダンスの応募も引き続き募集中です。
応募期間は5月3日から8月31日まで。
あなたのダンスがアニメのエンディングに登場するチャンスです。
かわいいおねがいダンスをぜひ練習して、応募してみてください。
最後に、8月26日水曜日にはおねがいアイプリキャラクターソングミニアルバム ウィッシュ・イン・ソング 01 デラックスが発売されます。
収録曲にはおねがいアイプリ！
やトキメキジャンプ、夢色ビリーバーなどが含まれます。
初回特典としてアイプリバースで使えるプレゼントコードも封入されるので、ファン必見のアイテムです。
予約も始まっていますので、お早めにどうぞ。
今日は大きな新情報が多く、アイプリの世界がますます盛り上がっています。
ゲームもアニメも歌もダンスも、みんなで楽しめるコンテンツがいっぱいです。
これからも最新情報をお届けしていきますので、どうぞお楽しみに。
以上、今日のアイプリニュースでした。